you might have thought that 2023 was
winding down for generative AI with more
focus on mistletoe and merryman than
models and the MML U but no this was the
week of powerful new small models that
could change the landscape of 2024 AI
this video is about f 2 and what it
means as well as The Madness of MML
brinkmanship with a reminder of all of
that exam's mistakes plus Optimus Gen 2
imagin Gen 2 announced just today and
much more f 2 was announced by sassan
Adella the CEO of Microsoft last month
but what is it and what does it mean in
a nutshell f 2 is a 2.7 billion
parameter Model A small model by today
standards so small in fact that it could
fit locally on a smartphone according to
the benchmarks and I will get into those
it outperforms models of comparable size
like ones trained using Mamba as well as
Google's new Gemini Nano if that wasn't
enough it also outperforms models 202 25
times its size I've been following the
Five series of models since late June
when I interviewed Ronan Lan one of the
key authors of the original fi1 paper
there were strong hints of F1
significance in my original July 2nd
video on textbooks are all you need I'm
going to try to give you all the
necessary background on f 1 F 1.5 and 5
2 in less than 3 minutes that's
borderline impossible but I'm going to
try essentially they retrieved a pile of
permissively licensed open code from
what's appropriately called the stack
there's 10 times more than they used in
there they just can't use it for legal
reasons they extracted just the python
code from the many programming languages
in that data set and also filtered for
duplications for 5 one they then gave
gpc4 a task filter for textbook quality
code that's code with appropriate
comments and good syntax to cut cost
they swapped a tiny classifier in to
finish the job that GPT 4 started with
that classifier essentially imitating
the labeling that GPT 4 had kicked off
they then got GPT 3.5 to generate its
own diverse textbook quality data and
synthetic Q&A exercises for more detail
on how they did that check out the
original video in July which featured an
interview with one of the key
contributors F1 got 50% on human eval a
coding Benchmark and all of this works
so well that for fi 1.5 announced in
September they added synthetic exercises
in common sense reasoning logic science
and theory of Mind furthermore they
trained only on synthetic data leaving
that additional filtered stack dat for a
separate model called 5 1.5 web what
they realized was that this better
quality data allowed for more passes
over the data called epox or think of it
as a student rereading those textbooks
in a September exclusive the information
reported that Microsoft was now heavily
backing those researchers behind fi as I
mentioned in a video at the time that
gave them the money and compute needed
to scale up fi that brings us to the
release in the last 24 hours of f 2 2.7
billion parameters trained in just 14
days on less than 100 a100 gpus for
reference it's reported that Microsoft
has as many as
150,000 h100s the successor of the A1
100s but what does it mean that the
model is now bigger 2.7 billion
parameters well more parameters mean
more connections could be made more dots
joined so to speak and with more compute
of course that means that they can feed
in more data and go over that data more
times the amount of data including
rereads or EPO was 1.4 trillion tokens
which we know is five times more than F
1.5 web what we don't yet have is that
full data set though the model is open-
sourced there's a link in the
description describing how to download f
2 a side benefit of course of training
on synthetic data is that it tends to be
less toxic data the toxicity scores went
down across the board for 52 and this is
before any reinforcement learning from
Human feedback if you're familiar with
the meme this could mean bye-bye shogo
thanks to synthetic data and there are
so many potential lessons from f 2 as
one of the researchers on the project
said our f 2 efforts prove that we have
been wasting enormous amounts of comput
on rather ineffective training data as
he put it throwing a kitchen sink at a
model has a big price tag and leads to
lower quality on screen are the
comparisons to Gemini Nano 2 and mistal
7 billion parameters and notice they've
also included a comparison to llama 2 70
billion parameters and yes given that
one of the other topics of this video is
going to be about the flaws of
benchmarks I know what many of you are
thinking can we fully trust these
Benchmark figures of course I researched
as best I could about F2 contamination
but I was fairly convinced by the
multiple lines of evidence provided in
the video linked from Sebastian bck the
lead author the relevant clip is from
minute 19 onwards and the clues that
something like this was coming were
around if you knew where to look when
reading the original 5 1.5 paper I noted
this in the discussion section they said
perhaps achieving chat gpt's level of of
capability and remember that model is
over 175 billion parameters at the 1
billion parameter scale is actually
achievable now you let me know what you
think of f 2 in your testing and the
only caution we know I would give is
this I remember from the original 51
paper that they mentioned that their
models have a certain sensitivity to
prompt variations in other words how you
phrase The Prompt has significant
effects on its performance and as the
length of the prompt increases the
models tend to forget ignore or
misinterpret parts of the prompt but if
these results bear out this is the
takeaway it looks like you can mimic the
performance on certain tasks of models
trained with a,x more comput so now
let's imagine a 1.5 trillion parameter
model trained this way essentially
imitating what a 1.5 quadrillion
parameter large language model would be
like that's more parameters than we have
synapses in the human brain and of
course that's not even bringing in
allowing the model to think for longer
with extra test time compute and system
verification Alla Alpha code 2 things
could certainly get interesting in 2024
before we move on completely from
benchmarks and Microsoft though there is
one more chart that Microsoft put out
that I want to highlight here's them
showing that with their prompting system
you can get
90.1% on the MML U now regular Watchers
of this channel probably know what's
coming next for hopefully the last time
that I'm mentioning it on this channel
that bench Mark is flawed in many
respects in fact I'm going to end this
video with a clip from my original smart
GPT video running through just some of
the mistakes on that Benchmark I'm
frankly shocked that at the end of 2023
it's still being used to compare models
to two decimal places of course there
Microsoft were comparing its prompting
techniques to Google's Gemini Ultra and
many pointed out the somewhat
disingenuous way that Google presented
its Gemini model particularly when it
comes to video analysis yes that was a
poor show from Google but I made the
point in the comments at the time that
such a demo is possible in the near term
I drew this uh can you tell me what I
what what is
that the drawing appears to be of a duck
or a similar bird on water before we
move on from Google though they today
just in the last hour released imagin 2
they announced it back in May but it's
now available via API and be honest
would you have believed that this image
is generated by a text to image model
almost for the first time I would say
that no I can't even tell that that's
made by AI image in two by the way is a
diffusion model and using it you are
indemnified by Google from copyright
furthermore all generations are
watermarked the quality looks stunning I
mean particularly if you look at the top
right and bottom middle images you've
got to admit that that is a frankly
shocking level of photo realism when by
this point next year it gets to this
level for text to video we'll be living
in a different world but I did say that
the theme of today's video is small
models and here is the 10 kg lighter
generation 2 humanoid robot from Tesla
this is Optimus Gen
[Music]
watching this video makes me think of
touch temperature and pressure
sensitivity as whole new modalities yet
to be fully explored I spoke to one of
the leads for robotics of Google
deepmind for AI insiders but I also now
want to reach out to Tesla cuz Optimus
is getting close but yes speaking of AI
insiders today is the full launch of
that patreon tier first and foremost
you're supporting the channel and I've
written a personal message to everyone
who's joined and honestly I didn't
expect this but the Discord for AI
insiders has proven to be great for
networking whether you're an AI engineer
in SE Suite or just interested in AI but
what is the content that's actually on
AI insiders well let me walk you through
the four categories first we have what I
would call Classic AI explain videos
bonus content just like you'd see on the
main channel in this collection I
released a video 2 or 3 days ago on AGI
timelines featuring extracts from six
expert interviews I conducted over the
last month plus of course my own
timelines next we have the AI insiders
podcast I call it my let's think siby
siip podcast not my normal kind of
videos more a stream of Consciousness
Audio Only reflection with access it's
available on Spotify or wherever else
you get your podcast then we have the
tutorials I've been working for months
on these are more for those who are llm
curious and like everything else feature
expert extracts and will be continually
updated in the weeks and months to come
finally we have the Insiders Arena and
let me click on this one this is where
you and any other member with a passion
for AI can submit explainers and I'll
pick the best of the bunch edit them and
film an intro the debut video in this
series is from none other than the
legendary swix on the rise of the AI
engineer he makes a joke about my
thumbnails but I'm fine with it anyway
the next video could be you and the best
of the bunch will feature a cameo on AI
explained many people have already told
me that they expense AI insiders for
work and I do want to reiterate that
just by watching to the end of my videos
you are supporting me more than I can
possibly expect and I'm going to do
something unusual at this point I'm
going to wish you a wonderful day before
the end of the video why because I'm
going to end with a few minutes of the
mistakes of the MMO youu which hopefully
I have to point out for the very last
time as always though have a wonderful
day back to Breaking the Benchmark here
is the question that started it all off
as you can see the question makes no
sense the text says demand reduction and
the answers are either 13 4 234 1 23 124
what on Earth is that about now remember
it was only human grading that enabled
us to spot this I reckon most companies
like open AI rely on autog grading by
exact match that would immediately toss
out any answer like these as a null
because an answer of A B C or D hasn't
been given now I should say it was human
grading that caught this and gp4 itself
here is poor GPT 3.5 bravely giving an
answer to a question that doesn't make
absolutely any sense at all I love how a
couple of times it changed its mind and
was like no no no D not B what Then
followed was weeks and weeks of me
following up every quote unquote mistake
with the official Source the question
came from when I found the original
Source I realized what the problem was
sometimes they just hadn't pasted all of
these statements when you can see all
four of these statements the answer
options make a lot more sense now I know
what some of you may be thinking maybe
it's just business ethics that's just
one subject and what it's a dozen
questions what's the big deal well first
of all business ethics only has 100
questions so 13 of them missing vital
context completely undermines that
entire subject and second of all it
wasn't just business ethics and it
wasn't just this same problem it
wouldn't always be about missing
statements check out these examples from
high school chemistry and there's High
School psychology Professional
Psychology microeconomics professional
law professional accounting and trust me
it didn't stop there I was genuinely
shocked there were innumerable factual
errors and I would try to trace down the
origin of each and see what the source
said by the way the problem wasn't just
with one source it was with quite a few
of these sources let's a random take one
of these questions how many human
polyoma viruses are known at present 100
1 10 or unknown this question comes from
Oxford University press chapter 21
question two I researched the question
myself and also checked what this
multiple choice quiz said the answer was
let's tick 10 which is answer C and then
submit my answers to the quiz and let's
see yes it's correct it's 10 by the way
the actual answer seems to be 14 as of
2023 but that's fairly close what does
the MML U say it says the answer answer
is a 100 and it goes on and on like this
some of the worst offenders are the
virology and college chemistry sections
just wrong answer after wrong answer
after wrong answer here's another
example this is what the mlu says is the
answer to this question B I tracked down
the question to a fall of 2011 final
exam in which the answer was B the MML U
had mixed up the order of the options
and therefore picked B when that was
drug users in instead of men but there's
one more slight problem research
suggests that both of those answers are
inaccurate and that happened multiple
times where even the source was somewhat
dodgy with its answers here is another
page of mistakes of virology and another
page for college chemistry and one
example that will particularly shock AI
researchers here we have a question for
which the mmu says the correct answer is
a the original Source says that the
answer is eight which isn't even an
option but this question was in the dev
set and if you remember from earlier in
the video that is the set of five
questions they use to teach the model
what kind of answer to give when they're
benchmarking in the mlu in other words
all 100 results in college chemistry for
every model benched on the MML is
compromised for example a model that is
particularly good at imitating reasoning
will now be imitating an incorrect
answer now you might be thinking surely
now Phillip and gpc4 are done with
finding errors in the mmu unfortunately
not we carry on into new categories here
was a question from econometrics where
again the source was incorrect but we
also have misspellings grammatical
ambiguity and formatting ambiguity
throughout the test I'm not going to go
through all of these but any one of them
could potentially confuse a model we
already know that models are very
sensitive to the inputs you give are
there any more categories yes there are
there are loads of Juicy examples here
but I can't get to them all how about
examples of of multi-question dependence
for example this came up in the
philosophy section according to singer
compliance with his principle requires
but of course it doesn't say which of
his principles or this one singer's
argument begins with the assumption that
now if you look at the original question
it gave the context of the arguments it
talked about the arguments and
principles from his book famine
affluence and Morality In the mlu there
is no such context and again and again
this comes up high school bio you can
see the two examples here now there is
one final category I want to talk about
no clear answer I'm not going to
categorically call this a mistake but
what answer would you pick here this is
in public relations when an attitude is
communicated what does it become an
opinion A belief a behavior a point of
view I think that's pretty ambiguous
those kind of questions were
particularly prevalent in moral
scenarios and public relations or how
about this are cryptocurrencies
expensive or cheap is there an easy
answer to that and there was one
question that I did about 3 hours of
research for what is the biggest cause
of death in children under 5 years old
and there are multiple sources that give
conflicting answers that type of
question where it depends what source
you ask was massively prevalent in the
global facts category and then we get
controversial questions like this in
security studies how do biological
differences affect the roles that men
and women must perform for the state
with the correct answer being gender
roles are a social construct I feel GPT
4's answer is far more nuanced this
question touches on complex and
controversial topics and while there is
evidence to support or a few elements
within each of the provided statements
none of them fully captures the Nuance
relationship between biology gender role
society and state responsibilities it
also picks up on that language must
perform for the state now remember these
are just the examples that I found on a
subset of the full test extrapolated out
that would suggest that hundreds of
questions are ambiguous or erroneous now
now A 1 2 or 3% inaccuracy rate didn't
really matter when models were
performing at around 25 or 30% that's
close to random and that was GPT 3's
original performance but now when we're
talking about AGI or human expert level
accuracy and models are being judged on
tenth of a percent 1 2 or 3% really
makes a big difference